♪ ♪
>> Tucker: EQUITY IS NOT A
QUALITY, EQUITY IS REPLACING
EQUALITY.
THE CITY OF SEATTLE IS SO
EXCITED ABOUT THIS, TO ESTABLISH
SOMETHING CALLED THE EQUITABLE
DIVISION.
WE ARE NOW LEARNING THAT THE
PERSON IN CHARGE OF THIS IS A
LUNATIC.
>> HI, GREG.
A SOMALI IMMIGRANT AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATE WHO HAS YOU SAY
NO WORKS FOR THE CITY OF SEATTLE
AND IS RUNNING AS A PROGRESSIVE
CANDIDATE, BUT 11 YEARS AGO THEY
THREATENED TO THROW UP A SCHOOL
BUS FILLED WITH KIDS.
AUDIO RECORDING SHOWED THAT IN
JANUARY 2010, THEY WERE RIDING
ON A SCHOOL BUS AND TOLD THE
DRIVER QUOTING A NATIONAL
SECURITY INCIDENT WAS GOING ON
WHEN THE DRIVER TOLD HER TO GET
OFF THE BUS, SHE STARTED
SCREAMING AT THE KIDS ABOUT
AMERICA'S RELATIONSHIP WITH
SOMALI AND TOLD THEM "YOU NEED
TO CALM YOURSELVES DOWN, BECAUSE
I COULD HAVE A BOMB.
LOOK HOW LOOSE MY CLOTHES ARE."
WHEN THE KIDS STARTED TO CLEAN
THROUGH EXITS, SHE CALLED THEM
COWARDS.
POLICE REPORTS, COURT DOCUMENTS,
EVEN HER OWN STATEMENTS AT THE
TIME CONTRADICT THAT.
SHE DIDN'T WANT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE, SHE WANTED TO GO TO
JAIL.
AND YET WE SHOULD NOTE SEVERAL
STATE AND COUNTY POLITICIANS ARE
NOW ENDORSING HER CANDIDACY.
ONE STATE DEMOCRAT SAID "SHE
WOULD FOLLOW -- ANYWHERE."
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER F